[Musik]
die Antarktis oder genauer gesagt der
Kontinent Antarktika ist eine
gigantische Eiswüste mit einer Fläche
von 13 Millionen und 660.000
Quadratkilometern damit ist der 35%
größer als der gesamte europäische
Kontinent dennoch hört man nur sehr
wenig über ihn sehr zu Unrecht wie
befinden denn dort unten gehen so einige
Sachen vor sich die wahrlich unsere
Aufmerksamkeit verdienen deswegen wollen
wir diesen weißen Fleck auf der medial
Landkarte hier bei visualpolitik einmal
ein ganzes Video widmen wir sprechen
dabei über die letzte Region der Erde
die von Menschen entdeckt und bisher
auch kaum kolonisiert wurde und trotz
aller modernen Technik wissen wir bis
heute noch erstaunlich wenig über diesen
großen Kontinent sicher ist nur das ist
dort jede Menge Wasser gibt Antarktika
beherbergt man 90% ist der Erde und
damit ca 70% der weltweiten Süßwasser
Reserven der antarktische Eisschild
erhebt sich an seinen mächtigsten
Stellen bis zu knapp 4.800 Meter über
den Grund wenn das alles einmal
schmelzen würde stiege der Meeresspiegel
voraussichtlich um etwa 60 Meter an
neben Wasser gibt es dort unten aber
noch viele andere Rohstoffe Ressourcen
aller Art bisher ist über genauer
vorkommen zwar wenig bekannt statistisch
ist bei einer so großen Landmasse jedoch
von einigem auszugehen so werden in
manchen Quellen ca 45 Milliarden Barrel
Erdöl und 326 Billionen Kubikmeter
Erdgas in den Sediment Becken Antarktika
so wie auf dem kontinentalschild
prognostiziert noch interessanter als
dieses ressourcenpotential ist aber was
die Menschen damit machen werden bzw
machen wollen anders als in der Arktis
gibt es in der Antarktis keine
einheimische Bevölkerung trotzdem gibt
es seit mehreren Jahrzehnten erhebliche
politische und militärische Interessen
an der Region die nicht allzu ferner
Zukunft zu ernsthaften
Auseinandersetzungen führen könnten die
Frage lautet also stehen wir vor einer
ihrer antarktischer Konflikte wer
erhofft sich die Kontrolle über dieses
riesige Gebiet und was will er damit
anfangen also zieht euch warm an und
passt gut auf heute begeben wir uns auf
eine Reise zur wohl am stärksten
unterschätzten Eiswüste der Erde das
heutige so hat übrigens in kogny möglich
gemacht ein ganz besonderer Sponsor der
euch nämlich aktiv vor Datenmissbrauch
durch sogenannte data Broker schützen
kann data Broker sind datenmakler die
eure persönlichen Daten überall im Netz
abgreifen und danach nicht nur als
seriöse Unternehmen verkaufen sondern
auch oft an Betrüger diese Betrüger
bombardieren uns damit unerwünschten
Anrufen SMS und E-Mails oder versuchen
uns auszunehmen leider haben wir keine
Kontrolle darüber an wen unsere Daten
verkauft werden aber die data Broker
sind gesetzlich verpflichtet unsere
Daten zu löschen wenn wir sie dazu
auffordern das Problem dabei es gibt
Tausende von ihnen und oft ist der
Antragsprozess absichtlich kompliziert
gestaltet deswegen resignieren viele
Menschen einfach und lassen den ganzen
Schmuck passiv über sich ergeben der
Sponsor dieses Videos inkognitet genau
dafür jedoch eine Lösung in überlebt die
Aufgabe bei den data broken aufzuräumen
und ihre Anträge zu stellen um uns vor
Betrugsversuchen zu schützen du meldest
dich bei inkognini einfach an beauftragt
sie in deinem Namen die lösch-anträge
durchzusetzen und verfolgst dann bequem
auf einem übersichtlichen Dashboard wie
deine Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es für einen normalen Menschen
nahezu unmöglich diese Löschanträge
selbst zu bearbeiten und sich vor Betrug
zu schützen also du was gutes für deine
datenhygiene und schau dir inkognit über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung mal an
außerdem mit dem Promo-Code politik.de
erhältst du auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die ihr Nutzen
und falls Du uns etwas Nettes tun
möchtest ebenfalls in der Beschreibung
bei diesem Video findest du ein Spenden
Link mit dem du unsere Arbeit auf
freiwilliger Basis unterstützen kannst
wir danken dir schon mal im voraus so
und wenn wir das alles erledigt haben
lasst uns wieder zum Thema dieses Videos
kommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist eine Art Südkontinent geben
müsse wurde in Europa schon in der
Antike vermutet aufgrund der schwierigen
Witterungsverhältnisse im Südpolarmeer
war die Überprüfung dieser These aber
lange unmöglich erst Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts war abschließend klar das
am Südpol eine Landmasse von
kontinentalen Ausmaßen existiert
allerdings war diese Entdeckung schon
mit ein bisschen Enttäuschung verbunden
denn lange hatte man sich die
Südkontinent als eine reiches Land
vorgestellt dass man kolonisieren könnte
stattdessen fand man aber nur eine
gigantische Eiswüste nur etwa zwei bis
drei Prozent des Landes sind eisfrei
nichtsdestotrotz erfreut sich die Region
seither regenwissenschaftlichen
Interesses und mittlerweile auch eines
Erwachsenen Tourismus aber wie das nun
mal so ist ein so großes Land erweckte
nicht nur rein friedliches Interesse der
Zeit beanspruchen ganze 7 Länder
Hoheitsrechte überteile der Arktis und
dies führte zu einem rechtlichen und
politischen wäre war das bis heute nicht
abschließend gelöst ist die Frage ist
nun um welche Länder handelt es sich und
worauf genau haben sie es abgesehen
warum ist ihr Interesse an dieser
Eiswüste so groß bevor wir diese Fragen
beantworten können müssen wir jedoch
wieso oft einen kurzen Blick in die
Geschichte werfen also aufgepasst
[Musik]
zwischen Gier und Wissenschaft
schon in der Antike finden wir am
südlichen Rand verschiedener Karten eine
Landmasse mit dem schlichten Namen terra
australis eine Region über die man
eigentlich überhaupt nichts wusste man
hatte ihre Existenz nur aus planetaren
gleichgewichtsüberlegungen erschlossen
nichtsdestotrotz wurde die Theorie von
der Existenz eines südkontinents über
die Generation hinweg weiter vererbt die
europäischen Entdecker der 16 bis 18
Jahrhunderts glaubten noch oft genug
endlich diesen unbekannten Kontinent
entdeckt zu haben all diese Behauptung
stellten sich jedoch früher oder später
als falsch heraus meistens handelt es
sich nur um eine der eigentlich recht
kleinen Insel im Indischen Ozean
trotzdem die Theorie blieb äußerst
populär 1539 ernannte die spanische
Krone sogar Petrus Stella aus zum
gouverne der Terror Austral ist das war
das erste Mal dass ein Land ernsthaft
Anspruch auf antiker erhoben nun ja
zumindest auf dem Papier denn obwohl er
aus beauftragt wurde ein Expedition
gegen Süden los zu schicken ist nicht
belegt dass diese jemals stattfand
tatsächlich wechselte extreme Süden bis
ins spätestens 100 auch bis in die
frühen 1920er Jahre hinein nur wenig
Interesse
in Jahr 1898 fand eine Expedition statt
unter der Leitung des Belgiers Andrea
gerlaschte gomerie damals verbrachten
die ersten Menschen einen kompletten
Winter auf diesem eisigen Kontinent von
da an bis zum ersten Weltkrieg
erkundeten 16 Expedition aus acht
verschiedenen Ländern die Antarktis alle
nur in forschender Funktion
die Sache änderte sich allmählich als
1903 eine schottische Antarktis
Expedition auf den Südafrika Inseln ein
meteorologisches Observatorium namens
errichtete nachdem sich ihr Schiff aus
dem Packeis befreit hat der starken sie
in See um in Buenos Aires Nachschub zu
besorgen dort änderten sie jedoch ihre
Pläne und boten der argentinischen
Regierung den Verkauf von Ohmenhausen an
also die Basis die Instrumente und die
beobachtungsausrüstung der damalige
Präsident Julio Argentino Rocca nanntes
Angebot per Sekte an und ermächtigtes
argentinische Wetter am die Station zu
übernehmen und von da an war diese als
Orca das Base bekannt einige Jahre
später errichteten dann auch
verschiedene andere Länder Stützpunkte
in der Antarktis oder nach oben neue
Gebietsansprüche darunter waren
Frankreich Norwegen und Großbritannien
so entstand ein wildes Durcheinander von
ungeklärten Ansprüchen die sich oft
genug überschnitten aber wem gehört die
Antarktis denn nun heute genau das
werden wir jetzt genau unter die Lupe
nehmen
[Musik]
niemals Land oder jedermannsland
die politische Situation der Antarktis
ist außergewöhnlich sie ist tatsächlich
einzigartig auf der Welt grundsätzlich
beanspruchen auch heute noch einige
Länder die Hoheit über Teile der
Antarktis andere Länder wiederum erheben
keine territorialen Ansprüche besitzen
dort aber seit vielen Jahren
Forschungsstationen im Allgemeinen
handelt es sich bei den Nation die
Ansprüche erheben um Länder die der
Antarktis am nächsten sind sie stützen
sich dabei auf das Konzept der
territorialen Nähe hier sind die eine
Liste der Länder die Gebietsansprüche
auf die Antarktis erheben und dann gibt
es noch viele andere Länder mit
ständigen Basen darunter die USA
Russland und China um nur einige
Beispiele zu nennen insgesamt gibt es
schätzungsweise bereits mehr als 70
ständige Stützpunkte in diesem Gebiet
[Musik]
auf dieser Liste rechtfertigen
Frankreich und Norwegen ihre Ansprüche
durch Entdeckungen die Missionen unter
ihrer Flagge in der Antarktis gemacht
haben Neuseeland und Australien
begründen ihre Ansprüche mit ihrer
geografischen Nähe viel interessanter
und komplexer wird es jedoch wenn wir
einen Blick auf die Situation
Großbritanniens Chilis und Argentinien
ist werfen wie ihr seht haben diese drei
Länder Ansprüche auf sich
überschneidende territorial angemeldet
das heißt die Briten besprochen fast den
gleichen Anteil an Land wie viele und
Argentinien
und das ist natürlich ein ziemliches
Durcheinander das ist in den letzten
Jahren trotzdem zu keinen schweren
Konflikten gekommen ist hat allerdings
einen einfachen Grund 1959 unterzeichnet
12 Länder in Washington den Antarktis
Vertrag dieses Abkommen umfasst heute 54
Länder und zu diesen Zielen insbesondere
auch die Anspruchsteller der Vertrag
legte die grundlegende Basis für die
Verwaltung der Antarktis fest ziel war
es einen Konflikt um den Kontinent zu
vermeiden und ihn für die Wissenschaft
zu erhalten im Grunde gibt es drei
kernpunktes Abkommens die heute
bestimmen wie die Antarktis verwaltet
wird sozusagen die Spielregeln in diesen
unwirtlichen Gebiet an erkennen das ist
im Interesse der gesamten Menschheit
liegt dass die Antarktis weiterhin
ausschließlich zu friedlichen Zecken
genutzt und nicht zum Schauplatz und
dagegen statt internationaler Zwietracht
wird sind die Unterzeichnerstaaten wie
folgt übereingekommen Artikel 1 jede
Maßnahme militärischer Art wie z.B die
Errichtung von Militärstützpunkten
unbefestigungsanlagen ist verboten
Artikel 3 Freiheit der
wissenschaftlichen Forschung und
Zusammenarbeit zu diesen Zweck Artikel 4
keine Tätigkeit die während der Laufzeit
des Vertrags durchgeführt wird das dazu
dienen eine Grundlage für einen Anspruch
auf territoriale Souveränität geltend zu
machen zu schaffen zu unterstützen oder
zu bestreiten und das ist noch nicht
alles der Vertrag wurde im Laufe der
Zeit sogar noch gestärkt seit der
Unterzeichnung des sogenannten
madrider-protokoll im Jahr 1991 ist
zusätzlich auch die kommerzielle
Ausbeutung und weitere Exploration von
Bodenschätzen ausdrücklich verboten eine
vertragliche Änderung ist erst ab 2048
mit einer 2/3 Mehrheit der
unterzeichneten Staaten möglich die Idee
dahinter ist dass die Antarktis ein
internationales wissenschafts- und
Naturreservat ist und es auch bleiben
soll um die Einhaltung des Vertrags zu
garantieren findet seit 1961 regelmäßig
das Antarktis Treaty consultate of
meeting statt eine Art Forum für
Entscheidungen über das Gebiet
außerdem ist seit 2003 das Sekretariat
des arktisvertrags tätig es handelt sich
um ein exekutiv-organ das den
Informationsaustausch zwischen den
Vertragsparteien erleichtert außerdem
überwacht ist die umweltprotokolle die
bei der Nutzung des Gebiets eingehalten
werden müssen das Sekretariat ist also
so etwas wie eine antarktische Regierung
auf diese Weise ist der gefrorene
Kontinent zu einer Art Niemandsland und
gleichzeitig zum jedermannsland geworden
aber okay ich weiß was ihr jetzt denkt
warum in aller Welt reden wir dann auf
visualpolitik überhaupt darüber ist doch
alles cool dort unten oder nicht nun
ganz so rosig läuft es keineswegs
angefangen bei der Tatsache dass viele
Argentinien und das Vereinigte
Königreich praktisch den gleichen
Gebietsanspruch haben und ich meine was
wäre eine bessere Voraussetzung für
einen ordentlichen Konflikt also passt
jetzt mal gut auf
eine neue antarktischer Kalter Krieg
[Musik]
des Vertrag regelmäßige Treffen ein
eigenes Sekretariat das sind zunächst
einmal tatsächlich gerade so
vorbildliche Institution internationaler
Zusammenarbeit zumal die Dinge dort
unten auch schon ganz anders liegen
zwischen 1946 und 47 führten die
Vereinigten Staaten die Operation high
jump durch diese umfassenden Einsatz von
13 Schiffen 4.700 Mann und zahlreichen
Flugzeugen in der Antarktis ziel war es
Manöver und Übungen durchzuführen um
Personal auszubilden und Kriegsmaterial
unter extrem kalten Bedingungen zu
testen Hintergedanke des Ganzen war
natürlich ein möglicher Konflikt mit der
damaligen Sowjetunion
[Musik]
einige Jahre später im Februar 1952
ereignete sich dann der Homepage
Zwischenfall damals gab ein
argentinisches Marinekommando
Warnschüsse auf britische Soldaten ab
die vor der Küste des argentinischen
gebietsmaterial an Lande
[Musik]
nur ein Jahr später 1953 eignete sich
eine ähnliche Episode mit dem Vorfall
auf die seption Island 5 britische
Marine Soldaten gingen von dort eines
Kriegsschiffes und Name zwei
argentinische Matrosen gefangen Grund
dafür war dass die Argentina begonnen
hatten auf britische beanspruchten
Gebiet eine Basis zu bauen mit anderen
Worten die Lage wurde immer kritischer
die Anspannung wuchs und wuchs
doch dann hat die Unterzeichnung des
Antarktis Vertrags die Stabilität in der
Region erheblich verbessert trotzdem gab
es Zwischenfälle der wohl kritischste
war der vorglandkrieg in den 80ern der
gefährlich nahe am Gebietes
antarktisvertrags ausgetragen wurde die
Sache ist umso interessanter weil die
Briten ihre Ansprüche auf die Antarktis
wesentlich auf die geographische Nähe zu
ihren dortigen Überseegebieten Stützen
also zu den Südgeorgien und den
sandwicheln der Konflikt und die Fortis
betraf also unmittelbar auch die
Antarktis Buenos Aires versteht es heute
die britischen Ansprüche dort unten als
kolonialen Übergriff und beansprucht
diese Gebiete für sich aber warte wenn
selbst das ist erst die Spitze des
Eisbergs das größte Konfliktpotenzial
besteht nämlich zwischen Chile und
Argentinien und genau das sehen wir uns
jetzt an
mangelndes Vertrauen
in anderen Teilen der Welt hörte man
nicht zu viel davon aber 1978 standen
Chile und Argentinien am Rande eines
Krieges Anstoß des Konflikts war der
Beagle-Kanal eine meerespassage diesen
Atlantik mit dem Pazifik verbindet und
von beiden Ländern beansprucht wird in
jedem Jahr beschloss die argentinische
Militär hunta einen britischen
schießfrucht der die Grenzen der Zone
festlegte zum missachten stattdessen
mobilisierte sie die Streitkräfte nur
durch die Intervention Papst Johannes
postes des zweiten konnte der Krieg im
letzten Moment noch abgeblendet werden
aber jetzt haltet euch fest dieser
Konflikt zwischen Chile Argentinien und
Großbritannien rund um das Kap Horn
schwebt weiterhin und zwar als
politische und diplomatische
Konfrontation die in den letzten Jahren
Schlagzeilen wie diese hervorgebracht
hat Oktober 2017 argentinien ist bereit
Großbritanniens Ansprüche auf die
Antarktis anzufechten argentin jetzt
Außenminister warente das sein Land die
Herrschaft über den Meeresboden um die
vorteileinseln und die Arktis anstreben
wird dezember 2012 argentinien ist
wütend über das nach der Königin
benannte Kontakt des Gebiet September
2021 Argentinien und Chile geraten wegen
eine seestreits im amerikanischen Süden
aneinander die Regierung in Buenos Aires
beschuldigt ihr Gegenstück in den Anden
sich 5.500 Quadratkilometer ihrer
mehrhalde in einem der südlichsten
Gebiete der Erde anzueignen der Besuch
von drei argentinischen Ministern in der
Antarktis hat in Chile für Unruhe
gesorgt die Spannungen Folgen auf die
Verstärkung der überwachungskontrollen
in Süddeutschland durch die
argentinische Regierung die mit der
Gründung des Grand Maritim comment
einhergeht ja das ist vielleicht der
wichtigste Teil dieser ganzen Geschichte
jenseits der reinen Politik arbeiten die
drei Länder bei der Rettung und
wissenschaftlichen Forschung zusammen
aber was würde passieren wenn sich die
Konflikte verschärfen würden
[Musik]
denn betrachten wir es mal anders
genügend Anreize könnte es dafür auf
jeden Fall geben wie Antarktis ist eine
riesige Kontinent der mit Eis bedeckt
ist bei wer weiß was unter dem Eis liegt
das gleiche gilt für den Grund des
Ozeans zunächst einmal ist die Art des
wie gesagt das größte Süßwasser
Vorkommen der Welt wir sprechen ja
immerhin von 70% aller Reserven dieses
Planeten außerdem ist der Himmel fast
völlig frei von Funkstörungen was sie
zum idealen Ort für die
Weltraumforschung und die
satellitenverfolgung machen könnte und
damit für Überwachung Spionage und
ferngesteuerte Waffenkontrolle
Operationen hinzu kommen noch die
erwähnten Rohstoffvorkommen die sich in
der Antarktis verbergen könnten über die
erheblichen Mengen fossile Energieträger
haben wir schon gesprochen und das waren
vergleichsweise vorsichtigen
geschätzungen in den letzten Jahren
haben einige Schätzungen ergeben dass
sie sich um mehr als 200 Milliarden
konventionelle Barrel Erdöl handeln
könnte die unter dem Eis oder am
meeresgrundschlummern mit anderen Worten
die Antarktis könnte die größten
Ölreserven der Erde beherbergt
[Musik]
und genau das gleiche gilt für viele
andere Mineralien die Antarktis könnte
eine enorme Rohstoffquelle sein und zwar
vollkommen unberührt und offen für den
ersten der vorbeikommt und gewinnt ist
sie sich zu nehmen beim letzteren Punkt
bestehen aktuell allerdings noch zwei
kleine Probleme zum einen ist es bisher
nicht wirtschaftlich genug die enorme
Eisdecke zu durchdringen um an mögliche
Rohstoffe zu kommen aber seit einigen
Jahren verringert sich die Eismenge in
der Antarktis und die Technologie
schreitet auch voran der Moment an dem
ein lukrativer Abbau also möglich wird
kommt immer näher zum anderen gibt es
aber auch schon die genannte juristische
Hürde denn natürlich verbietet der
Antarktisvertrag die kommerzielle
Ausbuchtung der natürlichen Ressourcen
in der Region zumindest bis 2048 aber so
weit ist das ja bis dahin gar nicht mehr
und vom gravierendsten haben wir noch
gar nicht gesprochen hört euch mal diese
Meldung an das chinesische Regime erhöht
den Druck zum Bau eines strategischen
marinestützpunkts in Feuerland china
will den Süden argentin jetzt zu seinem
Tor zur Antarktis machen und man darf
dabei nicht vergessen dass in letzter
Zeit China mit Russland immer wieder
neue Schutzmaßnahmen für die Antarktis
blockiert hat all diese Tatsachen
garantieren uns das die Antarktis in
Zukunft noch ein großes Thema werden
wird wir werden dranbleiben und bis
dahin sind die Fragen erst mal an euch
gerichtet wusstet ihr das so viele
Länder Ansprüche auf die Antarktis
erheben glaubt ihr dass es in Zukunft zu
politischen wirtschaftlichen oder sogar
militärischen Konflikten dort unten
kommen könnte und generell ist die
mögliche Ausbeutung von Ressourcen in
der Antarktis Utopie oder doch eher eine
Dystopie wie immer sind Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch was dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns ein Like
und teils mit euren Freunden um es mit
ihm zu diskutieren vergesst bitte auch
nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren
unbedingt mit glücklichen und keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung macht's gut und
bis bald
[Musik]